instead of facing the voters the
opposition turns tail and fled and fled
from an election instead of deciding to
let the voters decide they ran for the
courts instead and despite the fact that
I followed the exact same process as my
predecessors in calling a Queen's speech
the Supreme Court was asked to intervene
in this process for the first time ever
and it is absolutely no disrespect to
the judiciary to say I think the court
was wrong to pronounce
[Applause]
question at a time or whatever the
strength and intensity of feeling and
the passions to which these matters give
rise we must hear what is being said in
the chamber and I wish to hear the Prime
Minister the court was wrong to
pronounce on what is essentially a
political question at a time of great
national controversy so we have
opposition MPs that block and delay
everything running to the courts to
block and delay even more including
blocking legislation to improvements
invest in our NHS and keeping violent
criminals in jail I think the people
understood outside this house understand
what is happening they know that nothing
can disguise the truth it's not just
that this Parliament is gridlocked
paralysed and refusing to deliver on the
priorities of the people it's not just
unable to move forward it's worse than
that mr. speaker out of sheer
selfishness and political cowardice
unwilling to move aside and give the
people a say they CMPs demanding that
the people should be given a say one
week and then running away from the
election that would provide the people
will say worst of all they see more ever
more elaborate legal and political
maneuvers from the party opposite which
is determined absolutely determined to
say we know best and thumb their noses
at the seventeen point four million
people who voted to leave the European
Union the leader of the Opposition and
his party do not trust the people